bootleg cat podcast special guest my guy
representing Las Vegas man welcome
what's happening man y'all you know what
to do listen we got a whole interview
you could go watch right now but right
now we're gonna do the freestyle we're
gonna get to These Bars shout out to
Vegas let's get to it man
[Music]
flag on my face it ain't for Kobe [__]
sliding like a ice skate all you did was
post the [__] I need me a new pirate
sitting here with Pyrex I'm driving in
these shoes I call that a side step
buzzer beater hit him with that last
shot my new [__] is stashed by Rolly on
Cuban Link I'm a doughboy mascot crashed
out Ops going live and on my head there
he trapping he get fed there he stay
there then he's dead there scared where
we shoot out I don't give a [__] about
who else shout out his mama crib up then
his mama made him move out try to [__]
his dick she turned me down I knocked
this boo out finally caught him Corner
covered in his sheets left his shoes out
Feds all on my insta you can miss me
with them [__] they investigate
expensive all that came with suspicions
never with no pistol this [__] close
just like a sister a professor with this
[__] I question marks about their
sentence habitual criminal know I'm
standing on this business the murder
turned the federal I stand over the
witness I'm checking statistics and it's
all about logistics I got money on my
head Kev My Lifestyle a little expensive
ain't about no digits I'm sideways like
I'm drifting cold working 20 squares
come get this box of Triscuits on my
radar Death Jam I got AR since the white
[__] with a zip she got chimp that's a
big car got the rest of them in Bay car
who the suckers they are red shirt and
khakis like a [__] working State Farm
cause the [__] slipping took his chain
and his timepiece now he all on
Instagram crying like he Tyrese dry
snitching bomb in the pie flipping ain't
no drought tired hitting all I got is
side [__] my Mansion got five
kitchens let's go by the eyewitness
drive I'm feeling tired snakes is crazy
I'll be getting all this cake but I'm
power flipping Bishop streets is down
the street fat maker in the nursing Park
all the diamonds in The Vape salute you
with all my heart yo here's this quota
pay my album straight in order he said
no yada Paola I thought that meant
paying yo
yeah
big yada man with a plug real quick man
uh what What's out right now
um welcome to Argentina just dropped
dropping videos like crazy I got a video
to every song on that album
um it's out on all platforms ladies I
had dropped date night before that so if
you want to chill you tip of some wine
you don't cook it for your man just put
me on instead of the waffle color dude
you'll be all right there it is
hey I know you just watched a new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week